from inside our clubhouse this is the
clubhouse edition after all next to the
future hall of famer cece sabathia i'm
steven nelson and see i'm giving you the
ball for round two of this clubhouse
edition we had a blast last time with
smolty and lows did we not yeah we did
it was so much fun so i'm looking
forward to tonight you're back again for
round two with two new customers we got
two chairs let's fill it up right now as
we
listen up and you hear the doorbell the
mayor is in the building coming in hop
in her cece's here
good to see you my man fired up to be
with you guys he hit 300 in the show for
a dozen years just in case you forgot
three-time all-star and you don't have
to face it i said i'm glad i'm going air
with cece i just don't want to be in the
box with that just the funkiness and
just nasty sliders i'll talk baseball
with them now geez all right let's fill
that last chair with a 13-year
chauvette and former all-star and
chris yeah what's happening what's
happening what's up fellas what's up
what's going on hey see why i just want
to say
let's everybody take a second and see
how this man is letting his ankles live
letting them flourish trying to give
them their own instagram page
network showcase clubhouse edition j up
the lead off batter
see why you like this move from joe
putting them there i do i do i like
seeing jay in this situation after
scuffing a little bit hey slopes slow
down
that's a big yard out there that j up
that's 415 baby that's the worst
that may be out that may be a good
chance in angel stadium yeah
get that ball good that'd be the worst
though you crush the ball in that gap
you're like oh yeah you're like no i'm
out
good pitch change up great pitch to get
buster posey he's been a great story
this year came back too went down 3-0
there i believe yeah kind of came back
fought back the old backup slider the
best pitching baseball is that what that
was uh hey change up change up mm-hmm
but he definitely
had buster looking for something
different that's a great pitch right
there that's it right there yeah
crossfire actually yeah i was talking
about busted them in so that two out not
from yashremski no damage done one hit
aside zero runs we're through one full
come back to the clubhouse here's my guy
right here
i'm calling barrel right here oof okay
see why you have barrel tension
[Applause]
man
i love seeing buster doing what he's
doing right now yeah that was a great
play right there i got it look at this
calls him off
man wow
one fluid motion
did you hear the doorbell ring
[Applause]
this turned into a crazy inning because
of him he's basically base hit man uh-oh
uh-oh
look at him
[Music]
running the bases
he said i need that baby
he's like i'll show you how it's done
guys i'm gonna slap one to left run the
bases angels have runners at second and
third up one nothing in the third inning
two outs and lines it into left center
field that's going to drive in one
another runner is going to come home and
score this is a huge role right here
they got to get rindon going face wood
big
big knot for him
so that's another base runner given to
the angels with max stassey up for the
second time he does go that way with
some oomph to it toward the wall leaping
it able to make the play it bangs off
that brick wall
ward sent on around
toward the plate the relay not in time
it's two bases it's an rbi at that point
he's already committed to it if he pulls
if he pulls off of that it's still going
to ricochet and get away from him anyway
so at that point you and the center
fielder need to be communicating say hey
something over my head i need you coming
over here
and sometimes the second baseman will
run out there as well
because they could ricochet anywhere
this is what happened on almost grand
slam guys
the angels will have the bases loaded
with two outs trying to get some more up
right now four nothing outside ball four
rbi
and a five-nothing angels lead
very patient at bat by wong picks up an
rbi his first angels have scored two
runs in the inning and now rindone
will be stepping up to the plate
he's already driven in a pair of runs
with a single tonight here's the pitch
he swings at that one and lines it into
left field this is a lot of damage one
run will score two runs are going to
score a third is being waved home and
the throw will be late and rendon is
having a big night tonight he's been
quiet for a long time but he's just
driven in
three more and has a five rbi
night in this ball game and the angels
have just busted this thing open things
starting to get away
from the team that entered tuesday with
the best record in the national league
lifted in the air into shallow left
field coming in hard is upton and also
going back on that one is
wang and the two collide but the catch
is made by keon wong on that one and he
gets up limping a little bit that was
kind of a dangerous play right there
juan came out of nowhere
it really appeared to be upton's
ball right there
but kian wong hustling
and now upton is being attended to right
now i think it might be the uh left leg
that's bothering him and oh you see his
ankle and shin right into the calf and
ankle area along for upton it's one
thing that
this angels team does not need right now
two on nobody out here in the seventh
eighty-five pitches for genie now and
donovan solano who's over two tonight
will come up and there's a base hit to
right field
they're going to wave in the runner at
third no chance duggar scores
giants are on the board they got the
crowd into it
anthony rendon who's had a nice night
for the angels tonight oh yes here we go
baby
i told you you got it get it we face a
guy like alex wood you get that one big
knock then you get another knock and
then he hit that rock at the left for
four rockets tonight
and the angels would be only five back
and there's a swing at a miss at that
3-2 delivery and that is how the ball
game will end struck him out good job by
watson and the angels come away with the
victory tonight